[Music]
all right now tonight we saw a very weak
frail biden try to hide his destructive
socialist power grab with bumper
stickers and slogans and cliches
senator tim scott he called them out he
exposed biden's lies one by one joining
us with reaction to tonight's speech
outnumbered co-host kaylee mcenany
former white house senior adviser
stephen miller
it was a good line post-speech well i'm
not particularly the biggest fan of
lately chris christie
that was like a 15 year old with a
credit card kaylee that kind of made me
chuckle
yeah that's exactly right look joe biden
has met with historians to try to make
himself
fdr one notable difference as rich lowry
points out
fdr had a 200 seat majority joe biden
has the slimmest majority since the
final two years of rutherford b hayes so
that credit card he may try to make
himself
fdr but he doesn't have the mandate to
lead and just i i know tim scott has
gotten a ton of praise all well merited
i've just got to say to hear tim scott
say
america is not a racist country
that is what the american public wants
to hear an original sin is not the end
of our story redemption is
that inspiring message is the future of
our party
what a contrast tonight yeah joe biden's
friend
the former klansmen that he partnered
with to stop the integration of schools
because he didn't want schools to become
his words racial jungles
yeah it took lyndon johnson uh he was
the one that relied on republicans
historically speaking
steve miller you you have played a role
in crafting these speeches
stated the union joint session of
congress with president trump
um there were good parts of this speech
by america
sounded right like donald trump
never-ending wars we got to get out of
them that sounded a lot like
donald trump prescription drug prices
being lowered that sounded a lot like
donald trump i
said wow maybe he learned a thing or two
well there's there's no doubt that his
writers copied a few of president
trump's lines
but i'll tell you what joe biden can't
copy president trump's charisma
boy that was a dull lifeless boring
speech my lord uh i don't think i've
ever i mean i
say it but it's like he's a corpse i
mean you can't it's unwatchable
right i have never i have never seen
such extreme
ideas married to such
a completely dry text
i mean just from a pure writing
standpoint this wasn't a speech sean
this was a laundry list like a series of
bullet points read in order
nothing stitching it together no big
idea i mean compare that to
a year ago in president trump's speech
with all of the excitement
and the enthusiasm and the energy the
patriotism the optimism
this speech was literally like watching
paint dry
on the side of an old house i i i mean
this
and then you you watch the the i call it
the biden
shuffle it's like uh you know the little
baby steps that he takes as he walks and
little elbows looks like it's an effort
i i
it doesn't seem to be a vitality
in in in how he approaches this
and it's the hardest job in the world
world kaylee this is not
this is not for somebody that doesn't
have a high energy level
sure uh he ended his speech by saying
thank you for your patience
hardly the way you want to end your
first address to congress
look my friend and former colleague
stephen miller i got to say uh that last
state of the union by president trump
was one of the most
well-written state of the unions
well-delivered state of the unions i've
ever heard
it's about the american people and to
watch american heroes stand up
all across that room as president trump
acknowledged them inspiring our country
to come together
in unity it was a beautiful speech and
you just got none of that tonight well
done stephen miller
uh he'd eat you as a speechwriter last
15 seconds steve miller
america's at a crossroads 2022 is
everything stephen
don't be fooled by the boring lifeless
insufferable
language look at the ideas behind it you
saw an agenda
for open borders defunding police and
the largest big government spending
bridge in u.s
history well said thank you both hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else